here are eight great apps that make your
world a little freer and a whole lot
easier to navigate Waze is a real-time
crowdsource map that not only tells you
about traffic jams and finds the
cheapest nearby gas stations it also
warned you of speed traps police
checkpoints and ticket cans and get this
the info is so good that the National
sheriffs Association is pressuring app
stores to shut ways down a group of
blood tests could take and use this app
to communicate now they're getting
almost real-time location of law
enforcement open whisper systems red
phone and text secure provide easy and
to end encryption for phone calls text
messages and chats if you're on Apple
iOS check out signal meerkat and
periscope allow you to livestream
everything from your kids soccer games
to police stops directly to Twitter a
question for you sure a recording the
only thing blocking these apps is that
they're only available on Apple products
for now the Peacekeeper emergency
response system app cultivates
benevolence and independence and
communities by allowing you to create
your own personal emergency response
network so that your friends family and
others can come to your aid at a
moment's notice and you can come to
theirs and then of course there's uber
the ride-sharing app that almost
single-handedly undermined taxi cab
cartels
all over the world boston cab drivers
are protesting in the streets saying
that ride-sharing apps like uber are
illegal and taking their business away
goobers driving down a dark road by
collaborating with state and local
governments to keep that new competitor
but it's also true that its ease of use
and superior product has brought safe
affordable rides to neighborhoods that
never knew them before and of course
there's the reason app which is free and
available for every platform out there
it'll keep you up to date on the latest
news video and commentary about free
minds and free markets what are your
favorite freedom increasing apps let us
know in the comments for reason TV I'm
Nicolas Li